نهر لي متدفقا عبر الجبل الاسود وصربيا
والبستنه والهرسك عاده ما يواصل جريانه
لمسافه
1860 كيلومترا حيث يصب في البحر الاسود
عاما بعد اخر وخلال اشهر الشتاء تمتلئ هذه
البحيره القريبه من بلده بريبوع
باطنان من القمامه
زجاجات بلاستيكيه براميل صديقه حيوانات
نافقه وحتى الاثاث او الاجهزه المنزليه
هنا في جنوب غربي صربيا تتم اعاده استخدام
الات البناء لازاله اطنان من نفايات تسد
بحيره باوت بيج الشيء نفسه يحصل في نهر
درينا في البوسنه المجاوره والذي يتدفق
فيه نهر ليم في النهايه تمتد المشكله
لعقود من الزمن وتنبع من سوء اداره
النفايات والافتقار الى ضمانات البيئه عبر
البلقان الالات هنا تتعطل غالبا بسبب وجود
الكثير من القمامه علاوه على ذلك لم يتم
تصميم الرافعات لالتقاط قطع كبيره من
الخشب او الغسالات الثقيله التي يقوم
الناس برميها في النار يقول العمال انهم
جمعوا حوالي عشره الاف متر مكعب من
النفايات التي كانت مكدسه في البحيره منذ
اوائل ديسمبر الماضي وبينما تعاهد مسؤولون
من صربيا والبوسنه والجبل الاسود في عده
مناسبات بالعمل معا لحل المشكله التي تؤثر
على انهارهم المشاركه يقول نشطاء البيئه
ان هناك حاجه الى اتخاذ اجراءات صارمه
الان الدول الثلاث تتطلع الى الانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن المتوقع ان تبذل
المزيد من الجاد لحمايه بيئتها اذا كانت
مساع انضمامها ستمضي قدما